[موسيقى]
شريحه كبيره منهم من الاكراد الاتراك ومن
بينهم اكراد من دول عربيه لكنها الجميع
رفض التحدث هم
غاضبون لدرجه انهم يرفضون التحدث يهتفون
باسم حزب العمال الكردستاني داعينا اياه
الى الانتقام
لدماء الذين سقطوا اليوم المواجهات هنا
اشتعلت بعد دقائق قليله من مغادره وزير
الداخليه الفرنجه الذي ادنى بتصريحات في
شارع المجاور لهذا المكان الذي انا متواجد
فيه الان انا والمصور صبحي قال فيها انها
انه يوجه تعزيه خالصه للجاليه الكرديه
وانه جاء الى هنا بطلب من رئيس الجمهوريه
وقال ان الذين طلبوا تراخيص للقيام
بتظاهرات سيحصلون عليها وان جميع المواقع
والمراكز الكرديه في فرنسا ستحضى بحمايه
خاصه
وكانه عمده مدينه باريس الاشتراكيه عن ذلك
الاكثر وضوحا ميسون لناحيه اشارتها الى ان
الجاليه الكرديه تعرضت الاعتداء به ناشط
من اليمين المتطرف الجاريه الكرديه في
فرنسا اضافت ان ايدالجو عمده باريس
الاشتراكيه يجب ان تتمكن هذه الجاليه من
العيش بامن وسلام وباريس تقف الى جانب
الجاليه الكرديه في هذه الساعات المظلمه
كما قالت حرفيا عمده باريس ان ايلجو ايضا
كما ذكرتي وكما ذكرت انا زعيمه طقس اليمين
مريم لبان اعربت عن تعازيها عبرت عن
تعازيها ضحايا هذا الاعتداء وكذلك
بورن رئيسها الحكومه الفرنسيه
وقالت عمده الدائره العاشره ان
وحدات للدعم النفسي اقيمت في مقر الدائره
العاشره لي معالجه من اصيب بصدمات من بين
الناجين من هذا الاعتداء الذي وقع عند
حواله الثانيه عشر ظهرا بتوقيت المحلي هنا
في باريس قبل دقائق من 12:00 ظهرا وقع هذا
الاعتداء عندما قام رجل
بسحب مسدس اسود من داخل كيس كان يحمله
وراحه يطلق النار عشوائيا على من كانوا
متواجدين في شارع يقع ضمنه المركز الثقافي
الكردي فقتل ثلاثه اشخاص وجرح ثلاثه اخرين
وبعد ذلك تمكنت الشرطه من القبض عليه وهو
مصاب في وجهه جراحه المعتدي متوسط وهو كان
قام باعتداء على مخيم للاجئين قبل عام
تحديدا في الثامن من ديسمبر كانون الاول
من العام الماضي قام بالاعتداء على مخيم
اللاجئين اسفل الاعتداء حينها عن سقوط
جرحين كانت جراحهما خطره وسجن لفتره ثم
صدر عليه حكم
فاخرج عنه مؤخرا لان قرارا باستئناف الحكم
تقدم صدر عن القضاء الفرنسي بعد ان تقدم
محامي
المعتدي بطلبا باستئناف الحكم الصادر عليه
فاخرج عنه مؤخرا وقام بمقام به اليوم لم
يعسر بحوزته على اوراق ثبوتيه ولكن
علم انه يبلغ من العمر 69 عاما يهتفون
باسم حزب العمال الكردستاني
ويدعونه للانتقام ميسون
الجاريه الكرديه هنا لا تفهم كيف يمكن ان
تتعرض الاعتداء من هذا النوع وهي التي
تربطها على علاقات ممتازه مع السلطات
الفرنسيه ويعتبر الاكراد انهم مواجهه
الارهاب ببسالا فلا يمكن ان يتعرض الارهاب
من نوع اخر من النوع الذي ارتكبه ناشط من
اليمين المتطرف